ce soir sur le divan d'henri chapier
marthe mercadier né le 23 octobre 1928 à
paris dans une famille bourgeoise
stricte et argenté et la grandit dans
les coulisses son grand père était
directeur de la société des auteurs
dramatiques lorsque la guerre éclate la
petite mart se réfugient dans les cours
de comédie jusqu'au moment où elle
découvre l'horreur des déportations et
des massacres elle devient résistante à
l'âge de 15 ans ce passé nous explique
pourquoi l'irrésistible vedette du
théâtre de boulevard et l'exubérante
héroïne de plus de 70 films continuent
d'être une femme engagée
militante socialiste elle se lance dans
des actions de grande envergure tels que
l'envoi de matériel hospitalier dans les
pays du tiers-monde jamais en repos son
tempérament de feu dérange jusqu'à ses
meilleurs amis il est écrit que marthe
mercadier quoi qu'il arrive aura
toujours le dernier mot quelle est
l'image choc vous retenez de votre
petite enfance
une image d'amour une enfant unique d'un
couple d'une famille est une enfant
comble et comblée choyé adoré qui aurait
pu si après je n'avais pas vécu d'autres
d'autres problèmes d'autres drames de
venir j'étais parti pour être une pièce
pour être l'horrible petite perle du
bengale qui ne se remet pas sur 60 ans
mais alors là les gens dit qu'à l'âge de
4 ans déjà vous étiez sur les genoux de
mistinguett et beaucoup dans les
coulisses oui alors des kim et moi un
peu cette gamine pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
était là puisque apparemment ce n'était
pas la position de vos parents n'ont pas
du tout mais mon grand père était
contrôleur général à la société des
auteurs amis de maurice chevalier amis
de mistinguett amis de deux hausses de
taux devenaient de l'époque de joséphine
baker bien sûr lui c'était son métier et
quelle intelligence cet homme qui était
un homme de principes qui était un homme
qui m'a quand même balisé qui m'a dit
des choses très dures il m'a dit tu
souhaites après quand j'étais plus
grande il me dit tu choisis ton vertu
conjugue le verbe être ou le verre par
être tué verbe être le verbe avoir
appuyé un grand-père très bien mais à
l'époque il m'emmenait et j'ai découvert
à l'âge et à la hauteur où on est à la
hauteur des jambes donc j'étais entouré
de femmes superbes deux jambes superbes
et pour moi c'était le commencement de
la fête c'était très très intelligent de
sa part j'ai trouvé mais alors vos
parents eux vous en donner une éducation
assez stricte en fin de mois vous l'avez
dit vous-même et comment est-ce qu'ils
ont pris la chose sauf que c'est un peu
contradictoire dans ce cas là le père ou
la mère reproche son grand père lui dit
écoute ne l'emmène pas là commença ses
places ses salons mais mes parents
venaient à mon père était un mon père
était un héritier dissidents qui était
baroudeur qui était pilote d'essai
ensuite il a été fonctionnaire et il
était il était un homme très bien élevé
et en même temps complètement à côté de
cette famille de bourgeois non il était
poupe il était là aussi maman aussi ce
qui t'est jamais mes parents ont vécu
une passion de 53 ans et son adoré
pendant 53 ans et mon père est mort il
ya cinq ans et ma mère ne s'en remet pas
bien sûr enfin les c'est vraiment la
cassure la rupture d'une vie elle ne
trouve plus ses marques mais elle aura
six ans déjà grand besoin de
manifestations corporelles d'expression
corporelle ait ça qu'on dit d'ailleurs
et vous suivez les cours de danse
carrément est-ce que vous rêviez d'être
une danseuse étoile à ce moment là non
je rêvais d'être avec des adultes qui
étaient sur scène alors je j'étais
acrobates surtout j'étais pas danseuse
tepa petit rat l'opéra j'étais acrobates
et j'étais je faisais des équilibres en
haut d'une pyramide humaine avec des
adultes très très doué e mois beaucoup
moins visiblement puisque j'ai fait une
sud très graves et que j'ai été
les vertèbres cassées la colonne
vertébrale cassée on ne pouvait pas en
plâtre et j'ai vécu une expérience très
intéressante j'étais un an lié sur une
planche un an et demi lle sur une
planche à l'euro monnaie l'été sur le
sable sur la plage alors j'ai été
enterrés dans le sable et les petites et
les enfants me disais comment tu
t'appelles qu'est ce que tu fais là et
je voyais le ciel je voyais les gens vie
évidemment à l'horizontale puisque
j'étais couché et ça a changé
complètement je crois mon mon optique
mon mon éthique de vie tout a commencé
avec cette année et demie passées à
écouter à garder les autres sont bougés
et puis ce médecin était génial j'ai été
réparé et je n'ai pas était bossu et
alors j'ai j'ai complètement apprécié
jouit de cette de cette sentais que
j'avais recouvrer mais alors lorsque la
guerre éclate je crois que vous avez 11
ans 12 ans et j'ai 59 ans et huit mois
mais comme les bébés ou ça vous donne
les mois mais donc 11 ans et quelques
mois ma femme et moi ce qui m'intéresse
de savoir ce n'était pas le cas de tous
les enfants soudain vous êtes éprouvé
donc j'aimerais comprendre quelle était
la vie de votre famille à l'époque parce
qu'une enfant que ça impressionne autant
c'est assez rare il ya une raison non
oui début de la guerre oui oui j'ai
laissé très mal c'est vrai mais je t'ai
je vous dis ça c'était le côté pair
l'enfant unique on me parlait beaucoup
on m'expliquer on m'a appelé à la
déclaration de guerre paul reynaud à 17
heures a dit la france entre en guerre
j'étais là mon grand père me tenait et
il disait écoute parce que tu t'en
souviendras toute ta vie voyez c'était
on me faisait vivre les moments
importants alors que mes camarades
allaient jouer se moquait pas mal et on
disait ils ont le temps ma famille n'a
jamais partagé cet avis que les enfants
avaient le temps de vivre des épreuves
et d'être conscients de ce qui les
attendait dans la vie c'est peut-être
pour ça que j'ai été un peu plus
résistantes aux aux épreuves aux coups
durs aux catastrophes de ma vie on
trouve chez vous et c'est rare aussi
une adolescente qui qui est dans la
résistance enfin quand même enfin une
formation portait des petits messages
j'étais championne de course à pied ce
cours est très vite et je pense que
c'est pour ça je [ __ ] et bien j'avais
une bicyclette je courais vite et jean
des des services et pour moi ce n'était
ni du courage ni ni quoi que ce soit
d'autre parce que je jouais aux
gendarmes et aux voleurs
on ne savait pas du tout ce qu'on risque
un on l'a appris après en allant au
cinéma c'est une période de deux
confrontations à la peur parce que je
portais des choses la nuit j'étais tout
seul dans les bois la nuit hélas oui là
là c'est elle a surmonté la peur mais
c'est tout on n'est pas courageux et on
n'est pas si je savais vos parents que
vous faites oui mon père le savez mon
père les avait puisqu'ils étaient
exposés non non non non mon père avait
avec complètement confiance dans mon
dans mon ma ligne de vie ma ligne de
chance j'ai pas une ligne de chance j'ai
une tresse j'ai trois lignes de chant
stressé su multi plate alors déjà ça ça
veut dire que l'on partage au travers de
pas mal de choses donc il me laissait
vivre mon destin pensant que si je m'en
sortais ce serait important pour la
suite mais après quand même après ce
sont des événements très précis qui vous
détermine puisque vous avez des
camarades de classe qui sont déportés
dans les familles oui on a été tous
arrêtés moi on m'a fait sortir leur soif
et rocambolesque je suis sorti d'un d'un
local vont occuper parler les gens que
l'on sait par la gestapo et et les
autres sont pas sortis alors moi j'ai
été sorti par un officier allemand qui
avait des grands yeux clairs qui m'a
regardé pétrifié avec les larmes aux
yeux alors où je ressemblais peut-être à
sa fille à sa soeur ou un chef en quoi
il m'a fait sortir vite vite vite c'est
un des plus mauvais scénario qu'on peut
raconter d'ailleurs il m'a fait sorti je
me suis retrouvé dehors bon il m'a dit
national vital et courez et puis et puis
voilà alors j'ai rien compris et alors
il ya l'autre face de votre personnalité
c'est le besoin de s'exprimer sur les
plages qui est quelque chose d'autre
personnel la série alors ça ça a été
mais je crois que c'est ma génération
nous avons explosé nous avons exigé la
joie l'a fait et la lumière n'oublions
pas parce que on le dit pas assez que
nous avons vécu notre adolescence dans
le noir le fameux black out dès qu'on
voyait une petite ampoule une petite
lumière tout le monde sifflé dans les
rues en tempêtait les voisins en disant
attention les bombardiers vont opérer on
va on va être bombardé donc toutes les
villes étaient dans le noir les rues
étaient dans le noir on a vécu dans le
noir et moi voyez une des choses qui
matin le plus le moral dans mes
spectacles je ne supporte pas c'était un
projecteur bleus la lumière bleue la
lumière du du delà de la fin de la leyre
de l'insa c'est terrible je ne supporte
pas les met sous les projecteurs bleus
ça me coupe l'humeur alors au début au
théâtre vous aimiez la tragédie vous
juste de résultats je voulais je voulais
m'exprimer jouer des des héroïnes des je
te savais tout par coeur phèdre attali
andromaque hermione enfin et alors
maurice escande charles dullin parce que
j'allais dans tous les cours c'est
curieux puis je les connaissais donc il
était il était mort de rire il me
faisait ans j'ai encore michel bouquet
qui s'en souvient piccoli qui m'ont vu
dans phèdre avec des socquettes et des
petits cols blancs et vous disais bon
travail ça donnera du souffle même est
une jouera jamais ça et puis il me
disait travailler soubrette et là je
répondais non puisque je les jours est
gelée gelé travaillerait avec un metteur
en scène et c'est béatrice du san qui
est aussi ma beaucoup m'a beaucoup aidé
non j'ai la chance d'y l'indus année
puis qui les gens merveilleux conte
rencontré à l'époque marguerite moreno
qui recevait les jeunes comédiennes dans
sa loge on était là 6 fasciné par des
femmes aussi merveilleuse alors il est
ancien relais de votre combat pour les
femmes qui à mon avis a dû croiser dans
notre tête du moins beaucoup plus tôt
vous avez près toujours pensé qu'elle
était minoritaire
et et qu'il fallait à chacune d'entre
elles en faire beaucoup plus qu'un homme
pour s'en sortir c'est un peu parti oui
oui c'est sûr mais vous savez là encore
on vient la guerre j'ai ouvert les yeux
quand même présent à 14 ans on commence
à juger les gens les on les observe on
s'aperçoit de ce qui se passe j'ai été
complètement fasciné par le courage
silencieux et quotidien des femmes
pendant la guerre de ces petites bonnes
femmes qui cachait d'aider des
parachutistes des juifs dans la dans la
cas des parachutistes des aviateurs en
grenier a acquis au camp vous et
perquisitionnent et qui était interrogé
par la police la gestapo et qui reste
est d'un calme avec ce côté ménagères le
bon sens de la ménagère le courage de la
ménagère et de la mère de famille m'a
époustouflé et après j'ai analysé que
mon féminisme et mon admiration venait
de là parce qu'elles sont plus fort tout
de même c'est elle qui sont revenus
aussi des camps beaucoup plus que les
hommes absolument même finalement
physiologiquement on est plus forte on
donne la vie vaut mieux vaut mieux
protégés vaut mieux bien sûr on est plus
forte et c'est pour ça à 7,7 peur de la
femme enfin bon elle est ancestrale mais
les les femmes ont obtenu le droit de
vote en 46 et par hasard c'est grâce aux
femmes de la résistance c'est grâce
justement à ce courage quotidien et
silencieux alors là je suis féministe
par ouï dire parce que par solidarité
puisque moi j'ai jamais eu j'ai jamais
été maltraité j'ai rencontré des hommes
remarquables mon père d'abord mon mari
ensuite vers les zones de ma famille
j'ai commencé à regarder autour de moi
et c'est vrai que beaucoup de femmes
n'ont pas n'ont pas la même chance si
vous voulez mon militantisme c'est une
sorte de remboursement parce que on peut
pas avoir eu autant d'amour départ
autant de possibilités de s'en sortir
ils ont été infirmés bien soigné
j'aurais pu être mal soignée et puis et
puis m'en sortir en ayant bon fait des
choses un petit peu un petit peu
dangereuse sans avoir envie de
rembourser 2 de coopérer de collaborer
de dire mme mois qu'est ce que je peux
et ce que je peux apporter ma petite
pierre voilà la bohème et annonce m
tout à fait direct indiscrets cantona
cette ampera morts est-ce qu'on n'a pas
eu de mal à établir une relation avec un
homme même lorsqu'ils vous plaît et ce
qu'il peut être autre chose qu'un
camarade un partenaire à égalité est-ce
qu'on a encore un élan sensuelle une
ruse de femmes ça se passe comment ça se
passe parce que toutes les femmes de ma
famille sont raides sont très équilibrés
elles n'ont jamais combattu les hommes
elles ont combattu les lois le code
napoléon mais ne se sont pas trompés
d'objectifs contrairement à certains
mouvements extrémistes qui
malheureusement sans tromper d'objectif
non moi je crois ça dépend vous savez si
vous êtes si vous tombez amoureuse du
séducteur du plagiste du de monsieur
muscles ça peut difficilement bien
tourné mais si vous avez encore une fois
la chance d'être attirés par des hommes
responsables par des hommes qui sont
allés coûte à l'ecoute des femmes à
l'ecoute qui souhaitent fonder une
famille bon moi j'ai été mariée pendant
pendant 22 ans alors on peut pas dire
que quand on est on est beaucoup changé
d'idée et c'est pas moi c'est mon mari
qui m'a quittée pour rejoindre une autre
femme qu'il avait mis avant maintenant
il l'a fait avec beaucoup d'ailleurs de
de dignité j'estime et j'adore le père
de ma fille et ça s'est fait bien ça
c'est ça s'est fait dans le temps dans
la dans la dans la tenue et dans
l'amitié alors les autres oui ça dépend
ça dépend du choix vous savez mais c'est
vrai que des comédiennes et les femmes
qui ont une grosse activité
pour résumer un peu vulgairement on
n'est pas des cadeaux moi je suis pour
un cadeau dans ta vie on peut pas dire
aimer alors vous avez tenté une aventure
intéressante qui est celle d'accepter un
rôle dans le ministère d'yvette roudy on
s'en souvient c'était au début du
premier septennat de françois mitterrand
et là vous découvrez en somme une chose
que vous deviez sur mort c'est que le
pouvoir use également beaucoup les
femmes et que finalement il y avait des
résultats me médium
et dix ans c'était non il ya eu d'aidé
des résultats il a fallu d'abord imposé
ce ministère mahmoudi a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de courage aussi de me 2 me de
me nommer de me donner un rapport sur la
l'inégalité les injustices dans
l'audiovisuel pour les femmes qui
visiblement occupent des postes sont
très nombreuses et puis et puis plus
vous montez dans la hiérarchie c'est la
peau de chagrin les postes de
responsabilité se raréfient et puis nous
avons quelques femmes très importante
très voyant des alibis dix ans bon alors
j'ai fait ce petit rapport j'ai eu la
joie de constater qu'il avait été une
base de réflexion pour la communauté
européenne qui a demandé le même rapport
dans différents pays à des femmes
beaucoup plus structuré que moi qui
n'ont dû le faire bien mieux enfin
disons que j'ai un peut amorcer la pompe
et puis j'ai beaucoup appris auprès du
ministre des droits de la femme parce
qu'elle menait un combat pour la
première fois un ministère de la femme
avait un budget parce que ça aussi on
sortait du ministère gadgets où il y
avait juste l'argent pour payer les le
papier à en-tête les gommes et les
crayons et là on peut par peu reposé
reprocher aux autres ministres de ne pas
avoir eu plus de d'action elle n'avait
pas le nerf de la guerre
madame road il a exigé monsieur
mitterrand lui a donné mais alors est-ce
que vous n'auriez pas souhaité être
finalement une in iraq gandhi ou une
gold abx et yves une femme qui a une
vision du monde
comme vous et bâle a envie peut-être de
ça parce que là il peut quelque chose
pour changer
alors la jab y est je suis une gestion
rationnelle des femmes des femmes qui
qui ont une action envoyé mon ami mélina
mercouri je suis ravi qu'elle soit
ministre de la culture mais je lui avais
dit de continuer son métier parce que
maintenant elle est une ex actrice qui
est ministre de la culture je crois que
chacun a son petit terrain sa petite
place et qu'il faut pas commencer à dire
moi je
si on a une idée tant mieux si on la
mène à bien bravo mais c'est tout moi je
suis une actrice et encore je suis pas
une actrice je me suis un peu trompé de
métier si vous voulez j'ai eu j'ai eu un
choc quand je me suis vu j'étais parti
pour être une grande actrice je croyais
et puis grâce à la télévision et au
cinéma
un jour j'ai une projection de ce que je
faisais là ça a été quand même la minute
de vérité je n'aime pas ce genre de
travail j'aime j'ai trop connu de
grandes actrices pour laquelle toute
leur vie leur vie est remplie par leur
métier par le choix d'un rôle la
cogitation
moi j'ai été déçu par mon travail
j'ai vu que j'étais très limité j'avais
la chance de connaître très bien
rigoureux stremme michel simon
montreynaud yvonne de braire 20 j'avais
mes références visconti cavalcanti bon
j'ai dit si ce n'est que ça je vais
quand même vive parallèlement alors je
me suis servi de ce métier j'ai tourné
75 fimec tout mon coeur je jouais tout
mon coeur quand on même quand on trouve
ça mauvais je peux pas faire mieux mais
c'est pas ça une grande actrice une
grande actrice c'est madame suzanne flon
c'est c'est nicole garcia a scellé
nouvelle c'est la relève sont des femmes
qui ne vivent que pour ça moi je suis
toujours ailleurs lancé pas normal
je suis incapable de jouer une scène
d'amour s'est tournée 75e jésuites bon
combien 70 pièces j'ai jamais j'ai fait
supprimer je n'aime pas je ne peux pas
il ya des choses que je ne peux pas
faire alors bon c'est pas ça moi je suis
pas une directrice vous êtes toujours
une vedette très populaire simplement
vous vous ne jouez pas les stars d'une
part non et vous n'êtes pas névrotique
mais vous avez l'actrice a beaucoup aidé
la femme et je la remercie beaucoup
quelle thérapie quelle façon de se
reconstruire formidable là alors là je
me suis pas trompé de métier parce que
j'avais quand même un certain j'avais un
excès d'agressivité
j'avais j'étais espèce de volcan
toujours j'explosais sans arrêt c'est
tout ça à canaliser ses seins canaliser
mon agressivité en énergie et puis je
crois le public oui j'ai des
manifestations depuis j'ai été cinq mois
sans travail en 40 ans alors bon on n'a
pas engagé bank faire plaisir donc
visiblement je fais à peu près bien mon
travail mais
ce qu'on doit aimer c'est ma santé c'est
cette c'est tout mon coeur c'est que j'y
mets tout mon coeur ça je crois que
c'est ça puis j'aime bien les gens
j'aime le public
j'aime le pop ce qu'en disait tout à
l'heure sont les mêmes le peuple c'est
là dans la journée le public ça doit
partir de 21h mais ce sont toujours les
mêmes et j'aime bien les gens j'ai
besoin des anges j'aime la foule et je
crois qu'ils le sentent et alors comment
allez vous gérer map mercadier dans les
20 prochaines années et commençait sa
décrépitude
parce que ça c'est très intéressant j'ai
donc eu des accidents physique est une
chose qui me passionne c'est la
vieillesse je la vis comme un western
tous les matins à partir d'un certain
âge on se réveille en disant qu est-ce
qui s'est déclaré qu est-ce qui va
aujourd'hui ne plus fonctionner et puis
bon visiblement ça se passe ça se passe
pas trop mal on dit j'ai un petit sursis
mais la vigilance quand une actrice
signe un contrat elle doit être très
vigilante sur son apparence physique
surtout les comics parce que si vous
avez la moindre boursouflures le musée
si vous n'êtes pas en forme il n'y a
plus de spectacle donc vous êtes par
contre a obligé d'être d'une rigueur et
d'une si vous êtes honnête envers vos
producteurs envers votre public envers
vous même bon donc on est déjà un petit
peu ça ici c'est du nous avons une vie
dure et nous avons une discipline
d'enfer alors la vieillesse on est déjà
un peu un peu préparé donc dans les
prochaines années je vais gérer ma
décrépitude on l'a surmontant
joyeusement comme j'ai surmonté mon
retour d'âge comme g mais la maternité
m'a beaucoup aidé puisque ça la
maternité c'est c'est une telle fed
c'est je crois la seule chose règles
j'ai réussi dans ma vie thématique
[Musique]